voilà monsieur bonsoir aussi les titres
de l'actualité de ce jeudi 27 décembre
la mort de benazir bhutto tuée dans un
attentat suicide cet après-midi lé sud a
meeting dans la banlieue d'islamabad
l'ancien premier ministre et leader de
l'opposition pakistanaise était rentré
dans son pays à peine deux mois pour
mener campagne en vue des élections
législatives où elle faisait figure de
favorite dans tout le pays à l'annoncé
de sa mort des scènes de violence sont
multipliés la france a demandé
officiellement à la justice tchadienne
transfert des membres de l'arche de zoé
condamnés à huit ans de travaux forcés
les familles ont été reçus cet après
midi à l'elysée les hausses des tarifs
du gaz à partir du 1er janvier en france
+ 4 % en raison de l'augmentation des
prix de l'énergie
avant la réforme du contrôle technique
effective au 1er janvier les
automobilistes affluent dans les centres
pour faire valider leurs véhicules selon
les normes actuelles qui sont moins
contraignantes
l'extension du vignoble champenois pour
satisfaire à une demande qui ne cesse
d'augmenter les vignerons veulent
étendre les parcelles une manne pour
certains propriétaires terriens et puis
nous retrouverons à la fin de ce journal
bruno solo qui oeuvrent à nous parler de
l'expérience exceptionnelle qu'il a vécu
en mongolie dans les steppes t'offre et
des cavaliers des éleveurs rendez vous
en terre inconnue
conçue et présentée par frédéric lopez
c'est après ce journal
benazir bhutto a succombé dans
l'attentât qui la visaient cet après
midi elle a été atteinte d'une balle
tirée par un kamikaze qui a ensuite fait
exploser sa charge tuant seize autres
personnes
l'ancien premier ministre pakistanais
leader de l'opposition est morte peu
après son arrivée à l'hôpital
l'attentât a eu lieu à l'issue d'un
meeting électoral dans la banlieue
d'islamabad
loïc de la mornais se seront pour
l'histoire les dernières images de
benazir bhutto et dans le brouhaha le
dernier son de sa voix
en cette fin d'après midi après un
meeting à rawalpindi au nord du pays
benazir bhutto quitte la tribune et
regagne son véhicule malgré le nombre
important de caméras il n'existe pas
pour leurs images de l'attentât
mais selon les premiers éléments de la
police dans la foule un homme va tirer à
plusieurs reprises sur l'ancien premier
ministre
une balle l'aurait touché au cou
immédiatement après avoir ouvert le feu
l'assassin se fait sauter avec une
ceinture d'explosifs
les sentes un carnage dans la rue au
moins 20 morts ils l'ont tué ils l'ont
tué gémit ce partisan benazir bhutto a
été emmené à l'hôpital dans sa voiture
criblée de balles
son porte-parole ressort annonçant la
nouvelle
je suis allé voir le chirurgien en
personne il vient de me confirmer que
madame et martin
à ce mot la foule comprend qu'elle est
morte
nawaz sharif ancien premier ministre
membre de l'opposition mais adversaires
politiques de benazir bhutto s'adresse
aux partisans de la leader assassiné lui
même a réchappé d'un attentat un peu
plus tôt dans l'après midi
les temps sont durs pour l'ensemble de
l'opposition mes frères mes frères
militants du parti de benazir butto et
moi et mon parti la ligue musulmane
partageons votre douleur
le chef de l'état le président musharraf
annonce à la télévision un deuil
national de trois jours et lance un
appel au calme
c'est que dans le pays des émeutes ont
déjà éclaté
les partisans de benazir bhutto s'en
prennent à la police et aux symboles du
pouvoir
quatre personnes sont tuées dans les
affrontements ce soir à rawalpindi
benazir bhutto a déjà été mise dans un
cercueil
comme son père ancien premier ministre
aussi est pendu après un coup d'état
la politique lui aura coûté la ville et
l'asie rebouteux et est rentré il ya
deux mois à peine après huit ans d'exil
pour participer à la campagne
législative son retour encouragé par les
états unis avaient aussi pour objectif
de limiter le pouvoir du général
musharraf
elle avait déjà été la cible d'un
attentat suicide à karachi
âgé de 54 ans issu d'une grande famille
pakistanaise benazir bhutto était devenu
à 35 ans la première femme à diriger un
pays musulman
c'est une figure marquante et historique
qui disparaît aujourd'hui bernard lebrun
rayonnante de joie ce jour là après huit
années d'exil à 54 ans benazir butto et
son clan retrouver son pays et son
sourire légendaire versant des larmes
très médiatique au pied de la passerelle
buteau ne semblait pas alors craindre de
plonger dans le chaudron politique
pakistanais je suis très très ému et de
revenir dans mon pays et la foule est au
rendez vous des partisans surtout ceux
du parti du peuple pakistanais le ppp
ici souhaite longue vie à son leader un
leader menacé de mort par les islamistes
radicaux et menaces mises à exécution le
soir même de ce retour 150 morts
l'un des plus terribles attentats qui
est connue le pakistan est pourtant
madame buteau dit ne pas avoir peur je
ne peux pas croire qu'un vrai musulman
puisse tenté de m'assassiner
parce que les slams internationaux
destin tragique que celui de la famille
butô une malédiction va même jusqu'à
écrire ce soir la presse pakistanaise
benazir l'héritière est d'abord la fille
d'un lit buteau ancien premier ministre
renversé en 1977 par le coup d'état du
général zia ali buteau lui mourra pendu
en 1979 un martin la carrière politique
de benazir qui sera deux fois premier
ministre du pakistan est parsemé de
retour au pays et de départ en exil une
carrière politique
usé par les accusations de corruption et
les scandales du clan bute aux mets une
femme politique qui incarnait la
modernité et derrière laquelle très tôt
se rangèrent tous les militants
démocrates pakistanais star en occident
après ses études aux états unis nous
avions rencontré benazir buttho dès son
premier mandat de premier ministre
question que pensez vous de la charia la
loi islamique
la charia interprété par qui c'est toute
la question affirmant très tôt sa
différence benazir bhutto toujours
soutenu par les états unis
cet état liés politiquement avec nawaz
sharif tous deux grands opposants du
président général en exercice perveiz
musharraf benazir bhutto très combative
aborder le bras de fer électoral du 8
janvier prochain avec espoir
ses opposants eux ont préféré les armes
au bulletin de vote
le monde entier qu'on doit évidemment
cet attentat dont les conséquences
inquiète le président français nicolas
sarkozy a fait part de son émotion et de
son indignation et rappelé l'attachement
de la france à la stabilité à la
démocratie au pakistan
et puis il ya quelques instants bernard
kouchner le ministre des affaires
étrangères faisait part lui aussi de son
émotion parlant de scènes odieuse et
d'abjection ecoutez-le où il fait une
abjection vraiment que de considérer la
politique comme une série d'attentats
c'est un des endroits les plus dangereux
et les plus risqués du monde alors il en
va de la responsabilité de toutes les
démocraties et est ce que l'élection
peut continuer de se dérouler dans de
telles circonstances que vont faire les
partisans de madame bhutto tout ça est
bien préoccupant et et nous préoccupe
bien entendu alors qu'à new york le
conseil de sécurité des nations unies a
décidé de tenir une réunion d'urgence le
président george bush a dénoncé les
extrémistes assoiffé de sang qui veulent
le miner la démocratie au pakistan
la mort de benazir buttho donc deux
semaines avant les élections
législatives plonge le pakistan et toute
la région dans la certitude il faut dire
que cette partie du monde entre
afghanistan et inde est une zone à haut
risque de tout temps travaillés par les
extrémistes musulmans qui ont fait du
pakistan leurs bases arrières dans un
pays qui par ailleurs possède la bombe
atomique
le risque d'une révolution islamiste
inquiète claude sans père
depuis 1999 le pakistan est dirigé d'une
main de fer par celui que l'on appelle
le général président pervez musharraf
puissance nucléaire depuis 1998 le pays
dispose d'une solide armés il représente
un état créé dans la région depuis les
attentats de 2001 le président musharraf
est devenu l'allié privilégié des
etats-unis dans leur lutte contre al
qaïda le pakistan est officiellement un
des pays leaders dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme
le président bush a toujours soutenu son
ami général et dans les zones proches de
l'afghanistan
l'armée pakistanaise a multiplié ces
dernières années les opérations
militaires pour traquer les talibans
musharraf a toujours affirmé faire tout
son possible pour trouver et arrêter ben
laden mais dans ce pays à 97 % musulman
le président musharraf doit faire face
depuis quelques années une montée net
des mouvements extrémistes
on ne compte plus les manifestations qui
dégénèrent le pouvoir a toujours
entretenu des relations ambiguës avec
ses mouvements
l'été dernier par exemple l'armée
pakistanaise donnent l'assaut à la
mosquée rouge occupée par des
extrémistes il y aura plusieurs morts
mais d'un autre côté le pouvoir tolère
les écoles coraniques véritable centre
de formation des talibans aujourd'hui
mme bhutto a disparu avec évidemment des
risques de déstabilisation pour le
pakistan réel aujourd'hui quel
socialiste un pays fragile
l'année 2007 a connu un record absolu du
nombre d'attentats plus de 780 personnes
ont trouvé la mort le 8 janvier prochain
sont prévues normalement des élections
législatives
on ne sait pas à l'heure actuelle si
elles auront bien lieu l'avenir de la
démocratie au pakistan et ce soir très
incertain le président musharraf a
rassemblé son gouvernement
en réunion de crise parce qu'on pouvait
dire pour l'instant sur la mort de mme
et nazir buteau au tchad les démarches
pour obtenir le transfert des français
condamné hier sont en cours la garde des
sceaux rachida dati a déposé la demande
officielle de transfèrement pour
employer le terme juridique sur place
les membres de l'association poursuivre
leur grève de la faim est maintenant de
la soif
hier à l'annonce de leur verdict du
verdict leurs visages se sont figés
comme le montrent ces images que se sont
procurées nos envoyés spéciaux amaury
guibert
et frédéric ranque à l'heure du verdict
un silence pesant gagne la salle
d'audience eric breteau en tête
les six membres de l'arche de zoé sont
appelés à la barre et le président de la
cour égrène les noms avant de prononcer
le verdict tous sont reconnus coupables
les condamne à huit ans de travaux
forcés
derrière dominique aubry nadia merimi
est infirmière fond en larmes
les autres semblent proscrit sonnés les
visages sont hagards quelques instants
plus tard eric breteau et ses compagnons
signeront les demandes de transfert en
france
ce retour devrait être rapide sans doute
avant la fin de la semaine
le procès passés la procédure est quasi
automatique
même si les autorités tchadiennes
veulent montrer que rien n'est imposé
rien est précipitée rapide
cela doit être lente ce n'est pas une
préoccupation pour le gouvernement
tchadien dans les rues de n'djamena le
retour en france des condamnés ne fait
pas l'unanimité
la fota a été promise ition et anne sur
le territoire tchadien
on va pas des raisons pourquoi en france
pays qui a dit qu aurait promis l'attend
france vous plaît que ceci à dire on va
le transférer j'avais l'apologie
je ne pense pas le rapatriement en
france des membres de l'arche de zoé
sera sans doute le dernier épisode à
gérer pour les autorités tchadiennes et
française
avant peut-être de refermer ce dossier
éminemment sensible pour les relations
entre les deux pays
en effet pour que des membres de l'arche
de zoé soit autorisée à purger leur
peine en france il faut l'accord des
autorités de chad yens auquel cas les
travaux forcés serait convertie en
emprisonnement c'est ce qui a expliqué
aux familles cet après midi le
conseiller diplomatique de nicolas
sarkozy qui les a reçus à l'elysée
frédéric rota pierre monnet gier et
grégory vasseur
les familles des six français condamné
reçu tout à l'heure à l'elysée ont
obtenu des précisions sur les modalités
d'application de l'accord judiciaire
signée en mars 76 entre la france et le
tchad
quel type de peine subiront les membres
de l'arche de zoé à moins d'être graciés
par le président tchadien
ce qui est fort peu probable leur peine
de huit ans de travaux forcés inconnu
dans notre droit pourrait être commuée
en réclusion criminelle pour combien de
temps une fois détenu en france les six
membres de l'association bénéficieront
du régime habituel avec toute une
panoplie de remise de peine et
éventuellement une réduction de moitié
de leurs condamnations
on peut penser des permissions de sortir
pour commencer la libération
conditionnelle la semi-liberté placement
sous bracelet électronique
dès lors que les conditions légales sont
remplies dans tous les cas les tchadiens
devront être consultées à la question
qui devra payer les 6 millions d'euros
demandés par la justice tchadienne
la réponse est loin d'être claire ce
n'est certainement pas l'arche de zoé
dont les finances sont au plus bas
il y aura sans doute un des négociations
entre l'état de chats diagne est un
français qui tu as qu'ensuite d'état
français ce supplice retourne
éventuellement contre les condamnés de
l'arche de zoé
enfin pour eric breteau et ses amis
l'hypothèse d'un autre procès n'est pas
à exclure puisque plusieurs dizaines de
couples français désireux d'adopter mais
s'estimant trahis y ont déposé plainte
contre l'association en mauritanie après
l'assassinât de quatre touristes
français lundi plusieurs milliers de
personnes ont manifesté aujourd'hui
réclament en justice contre les
meurtriers et les trois suspects proches
d'un groupe terroriste affilié à al
qaïda aurait été localisé dans le nord
du sénégal
au venezuela le président hugo chavez
met la dernière main aux détails de
l'opération de récupération des trois
otages en colombie leur libération
pourrait avoir lieu demain sous l'égide
de la croix rouge avec la présence
d'observateurs comme par exemple
l'ambassadeur de france sur place
renaud bernard et franck pressée le
compte à rebours a été lancé par au goût
de chavez
les familles de consuelo gonzalez
prisonnière des farc depuis 2001 et de
clara rojas enlevée quelques mois après
avec une raie bettencourt veut le croire
que la libération est imminente
on est grand on espère les revoir d'ici
quelques heures nous a tenus informés
directement
on remercie beaucoup le président le
ministre des affaires étrangères d'avoir
accepté ce plan ça va de l'avant ce plan
accepté par la colombie c'est le
président vénézuélien qu'il a imaginé la
présenter à ses ministres et à
l'ambassadeur de france impliqués dans
l'opération sur une carte le commandant
chavez leur explique que les otages sont
toujours en colombie à 500 km à
l'intérieur du pays
ils sont cernés par l'armée près 6
chavez pour les récupérer il va falloir
lancer une caravane aériennes
humanitaires avec des avions et des
hélicoptères pour les ramener
et là lorsque nous aurons le feu vert et
de l'opération sera lancée
jamais très montrer y est mais rogers se
montrer dans l'hélicoptère comores a
désigné pour l'heure les médiateurs qui
discute avec les farc règle les derniers
détails de l'opération de taches noires
et
un matin la présidence vénézuélienne
fait savoir que les otages se trouvent
seulement à trois heures et demie
d'avion de caracas la dernière ligne
droite avant la liberté
en france les tarifs du gaz vont
augmenter de 4% le 1er janvier c'est
moins que ce que réclamait gaz de france
il s'agit en fait de répercuter la
hausse des produits pétroliers
explications sophie brunet dominique
beaune chez ce retraité de bergerac
tout est au gaz chauffage et cuisinières
sa facture s'élève à 890 euros par an
les tarifs vont augmenter de 4%
il répond économies d'énergie la
première conséquence est vrai dire la
température déjà déjà la ramenèrent
réunionnais température aussi si on
baisse d'un degré
sûr que la chaudière ne se mettra pas en
route donc on consomme moins d'eau
depuis mai 2006 gds n'avait pas augmenté
ses tarifs les cours mondiaux du gaz
sont indexés sur ceux du pétrole qui ont
flambé cette année pour amortir la
hausse gdf avait donc demandé au
gouvernement plus de 6% d'augmentation
le gouvernement à la fois pris en compte
la donne internationale qui fait que les
prix évoluent et que la france n'est pas
productrice de gaz donc il faut bien
répercuter des hausses qui existe un gaz
de france achète son gaz à l'étranger
mais en même temps il a pris en compte
le pouvoir d'achat des ménages selon le
gouvernement l'augmentation moyenne pour
les 7 millions de français qui se
chauffent au gaz sera de 3 euros par
mois pour les associations de
consommateurs c'est une nouvelle
atteinte au pouvoir d'achat en europe le
luxembourg et le royaume uni sont les
pays les moins chères la suède et le
danemark les plus chers la france avec
le tarif régulier se situe sous la
moyenne européenne
le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi a
baissé au mois de novembre -0 7% ce qui
correspond à 12 mille cinq cents
personnes
il ya désormais un million neuf cent
sept mille cent demandeurs d'emploi
inscrits en france pour échapper aux
nouvelles normes du contrôle technique
automobile applicable à partir du 1er
janvier beaucoup d'automobilistes
précipitent dans les centres afin
d'éviter une addition plus lourdes et
des réparations supplémentaires et
reportages et explications diego garcia
et pascal caron hopley complet complet
on ne doit pas sa frappe de changer 2008
une file d'attenté de plus en plus
importante ce centre de contrôle
technique à paris est submergé par des
clients qui veulent un rendez-vous avant
la date fatidique du 1er janvier
j'ai une voiture qu'à huit ans donc
après tout je vais faire un contrôle
technique autant autant de chansons sur
ce coup-là prévoyance
prévoyante car à partir de mètres du
prochain les contrôles seront plus
sévères plus complet et plus onéreux il
y aura désormais obligations de
réparation sur plus de points retour au
garage même pour un caoutchouc en
mauvais état sur la [ __ ] de frein
idem pour les amortisseurs et les
suspensions défectueux ça va obliger les
gens avec ces gens des défauts constatés
çà veut les obliger à faire réparer leur
voiture ou alors carrément
les mineurs voiture du marché pour
procéder à ces contrôles plus poussés
les centres vont devoir investir dans du
matériel sophistiqué
aujourd'hui les tests coûte de 50 à 60
euros demain ce sera plus cher
de plus ils vont passer de 30 à 45
minutes par une influence sur les prix
oui les cinq ans montrant moins profond
dans une journée forcément ou d'un
contrat mais je vous rassure pas de 50%
mais plutôt de quatre et demi à 10 %
glissement
enfin les centres auront pour obligation
de transmettre tous les résultats aux
préfectures un moyen de dissuader les
tricheurs dans la somme à flesselles
quatre membres d'une même famille sont
morts dans l'incendié de leur maison le
feu s'est propagé très rapidement dans
cette maison traditionnelle picarde fait
de torcher de colombages seul survivant
de ce drame le plus jeune enfant du
couple âgé de 7 ans qui dormait cette
nuit là chez sa grand-mère en banlieue
parisienne plusieurs sans papiers ont
entamé une grève de la faim dans un
centre de rétention au mesnil-amelot 114
personnes en 7 juin régulière sont
retenus dans ce centre ils protestent
contre leurs conditions d'arrestation et
de détention paul hinder dilly et bruno
bini
derrière ces grillages des sans-papiers
algériens indiens africains
ils sont plus d'une centaine au centre
de rétention du mesnil amelot juste à
côté de l'aéroport de roissy charles de
gaulle abou dia nord et leurs porte
parole
face aux caméras il emploie des mots
extrême
et
il
d'après nos informations près de la
moitié des sans papiers ont entamé une
grève de la faim
la préfecture elle affirme que la
situation est normale
les protestataires ont parfaitement
ciblé leurs doléances
ils n'ont pas écrit aux autorités
françaises mais au consul de leur pays
d'origine
ceux ci peuvent refuser de les ré
admettre sur leur territoire et ainsi
bloquer toute expulsion pour l'instant
ces requêtes sont restées sans réponse
ne savent pas quelle va être leur destin
ils ne savent pas s'ils l'ont fait
expulser ou pas ils ne savent pas s'ils
vont être libérés ou pas ils ne savent
pas si le consulat va délivrer un
laissez-passer et toutes ces inconnues
les maintient dans une ignorance qui les
rend extrêmement anxieux le ministère de
l'immigration a refusé de répondre
en l'absence de brice hortefeux
actuellement en vacances ce type de
protestation est fréquent dans les
centres de rétention
mais rares sont les mouvements organisés
comme celui ci la pointe à pitre un
hommage était rendu aujourd'hui aux sept
morts de l'incendié du magasin il ya six
jours notre présence de christian
estrosi secrétaire d'état à l'outre-mer
est entouré de deux mille personnes qui
se sont donc rassemblés pour cet hommage
quatre mineurs ont été mises en examen
il serait à l'origine du sinistre et de
l' incendie de ce magasin
l'interdiction de fumer dans les bars
tabacs bars restaurants discothèques
casinos s'appliquera à partir du 1er
janvier policiers gendarmes devront
faire respecter la loi avec rigueur mais
discernement indique le ministère de
l'intérieur
de leur côté les professionnels
organisent des espaces ou des terrasses
extérieures pour les fumeurs nicolas le
marinier et samia lui mais dans ce
bistrot parisien quand on parle
d'interdiction de fumer le patron est
clair et net
la solution est le cerveau n'appliquera
pas la loi tout simplement
le buraliste laissera fumée qui le
voudra quitte à payer l amende de 150
euros par infraction
la ministre de la santé propose une
solution à l'extérieur le droit de fumer
sur les terrasses couvertes avec au
moins un côté ouvert comme celle ci par
exemple
encore faut-il avoir la place d'en
installer une ya des endroits où c'est
impossible à appliquer dans des petites
rues étroites dans même fracturation pas
de tabac l'extérieur que tu as un
possible accord au comptoir les clients
ne sont ce pas vraiment enthousiaste
génère autant pour nous que pour les
cafetiers devait y avoir un autre effet
ils devraient la barre des bars où on
peut fumer des barreaux se passe mais en
plus les terrasse chauffée l'hiver ça
consomme de l'énergie ça pollue et les
bâches façon rideau de douche c'est pas
très beau bref les débitants de tabac
préfère de loin leurs propres solutions
je demande à ce qu'il y ait la
possibilité d'adapter leur établissement
une pièce qu'ils soient évidemment
équipé d'épurateur extracteurs d'air
homologué par la santé et qu'ils
puissent accepter les fumeurs en toute
convivialité comme c'est le cas
actuellement
il y à un mois 17000 buralistes
manifestaient en masse pour défendre
leur profession qu'ils disent menacés
par l'interdiction de fumer dans les
lieux publics
depuis il n'y a eu aucun compromis la
loi s'appliquera donc à la lettre le 1er
janvier et en italie où la mesure est
appliquée depuis maintenant deux ans les
clients et les restaurateurs se sont
bien accommodés de cette interdiction
reportage samah soula et karine
guillaumat les italiens sont fiers
d'être pour une fois présentés comme des
modèles de discipline deux ans qu'il est
interdit de fumer dans les bars et
restaurants
une loi anti tabac qui s'est imposée en
douceur même aux inconditionnels de la
cigarette ça m'a permis de moins fumer
et quand je rentre chez moi mes
vêtements ne sont plus la cigarette
c'est vraiment mieux même pour les
fumeurs fini donc l'expresso clope au
bar une habitude pourtant chère aux
italiens les fumeurs ne boivent pas
moins de café ils le prennent juste un
peu plus vite
maintenant il ya plus de fumeurs pour
m'accommoder avant il se mettait là
devant moi et me cracher leur fumée à la
figure moi qui suis non fumeurs à rome
les nombreuses terrasses offre qu'une
solution aux fumeurs mais les allers
retours entre latapie l'extérieur
sont entrés dans les moeurs au départ
c'était dur de perdre l'habitude
d'allumer une cigarette à la fin du
repas mais maintenant on sort et on fait
même des rencontres dehors satisfaction
également chez les restaurateurs leur
crainte de voir leur chiffre d'affaires
baisser plus vite dissiper
au début il y a une petite baisse de
fréquentation mais très vite la
clientèle est revenu et on à
retravailler normalement
forts de leur expérience les
restaurateurs italiens veulent même
rassuré leurs confrères français il se
tranquillisent il continue à aller au
restaurant il sort tu mais il n'y a pas
à s'inquiéter
les italiens ont très vite adopté la loi
anti-tabac mais deux ans après il est
encore trop tôt pour savoir si elle a
vraiment fait diminuer le nombre de
fumeurs et cette interdiction aura sans
doute des incidences sur la santé il
faut dire que de plus en plus de
français souffrent de bronchite
chronique une maladie qui fatigue qui
pourtant peut se soigner reportage
nicolas chateauneuf et pascal caron
expiré a inspiré pour la plupart d'entre
nous cela paraît naturel mais pour
pierre lehmann c'est un peu plus
compliqué à 79 ans il est atteint de
broncho-pneumopathie chronique
obstructive ou bepc au les symptômes des
bronches encombrées une respiration des
efforts difficiles mais depuis ses
séances de sport et de massages chez
sakineh salah mieux je ne pouvais plus
il ya quelques temps faire 150 mètres de
son maître à tous cas c'est en marchant
juste obligé de m'arrêter
depuis 16 ans ces séances d'entraînement
je marche
convenable on en un mois ce qui exercice
de coordination de musculation pendant
plus d'une heure pierre lehmann va se
dépenser sous le contrôle de sakineh il
faut remettre en état les muscles qui
s'était progressivement atrophiée et
mettre fin au cercle vicieux plus haut
du jour ça va plus le corps est - il en
fait donc moins les personnes bouge plus
- il bouge plus à y perdre du muscle ou
faire des capacités physiques
donc moi elle sort de chez eux aussi
donc c'est une spirale du ray le bouddha
spirale c'est le déconditionnement
sociale pierre lehmann a fumé pendant
près de 50 ans sa maladie deux millions
et demi de français la partagent souvent
sans le savoir
pourtant un traitement par médicaments
et une activité physique contrôler
permettent souvent d'éviter les
complications et de respirer plus
librement
c'est demain que l'on saura si miss
france gard nous non sa couronne valérie
bègue sera auditionné par le comité
raison de tant d'émoi quelques photos
somme toute innocente où elle pose en
maillot de bain et en t-shirt mouillé
nabila taboury laetitia legendre et
marie-caze
et du soutien valérie bègue en a bien
besoin de retour ce matin de son île
natale la jeune femme affiche un sourire
de circonstance
après une semaine forte en émotions elle
est passée du statut de reine de france
à celui de miss en sursis il ya trois
semaines est miss réunion remporté la
couronne devant miss nouvelle calédonie
le début d'un conte de fées
les réunionnais attendait ça depuis 30
ans et puis il ya eu ces photos
suggestives publiée dans le magazine
entrevue
valérie bègue plaide l'erreur de
jeunesse geneviève de fontenay lui
demande de démissionner on ne badine pas
avec le règlement
comme le rappelle une ancienne miss
france je comprends très bien l'émotion
à la réunion je comprends que les
réunionnais ont font très fier d'avoir
d'avoir ou miss france 2008 comme
ambassadrice
je comprends également beaucoup la vie
damman la position de geneviève de
fontenay
mais dans cette sorte ce qui est
important c est s'en tenir aux faits des
faits qui seront évoqués deux mains lors
d'un comité miss france extraordinaire
valérie bègue risque d'y laisser sa
couronne pour le patron du magazine
entrevue
c'est beaucoup de bruit pour pas grand
chose l'institution miss france on nous
vend toujours c'est ce jeune fille qui
sont presque vierge
voilà donc qui reprit catholique
pratiquante
donc c'est pas le cas c'est tout donc ce
que je voulais dire ils ont tout fait du
maninka du mannequinat je pense
qu'aujourd'hui cette élection de miss
france est un peu surréaliste
si valérie bègue était destitué la
couronne reviendrait à sa première
dauphine miss nouvelle calédonie dans le
monde très feutré lewis ce serait une
première
restons dans le pétillant avec
l'extension du vignoble de champagne à
la demande ne cesse d'augmenter
mais la production est limité la hausse
des rendements ne suffit plus de
nouvelles terres sont conquises dans les
départements voisins
caroline tu éboué lionel langlade voix
laisser passer les frais c'est plus on
commence à taez tailler les vignes
cette famille sans charge depuis 300 ans
mais aujourd'hui l'heure sept hectares
ne suffisent plus la production atteint
son maximum il espère pouvoir bientôt
planter ce champ on a planté
saisine jusque dans l'est dans les
années 60 et on s'est arrêté sur le
chemin il n'y a aucune différence c'est
exactement le même sol argilo-calcaire
saule blanc crayeux champenois si leur
chant devient un vignoble
son prix pourrait être multiplié par
deux cent pour atteindre 1 million
d'euros l'hectare
l'extension de l'appellation champagne
ici en rose leur permettrait surtout de
mieux faire face à l'explosion des
ventes et des exportations +14 % l'année
dernière trois quarts des bouteilles de
cette grande maison parc vers
l'angleterre les etats-unis mais aussi
l'inde la chine selon un l'extension
donnera un coup de pouce au marché
elle permettra probablement à terme de
faire passer la production annuelle de
champagne de 300 à 400 millions de
bouteilles mais sans changer rien elle
est faite pénurie puisque la
consommation et la demande va augmenter
elle aussi les prix de ces bouteilles ne
devrait donc pas baissé mais pour ce
représentant de vignerons la révision de
l'appellation ans renforcera la qualité
la preuve c'est qu'on a quelques
communes qui d'ailleurs monte ou en
sortir de l'appellation parce que
qualitativement bas ils ont pas
forcément les terroirs l'exposition le
champagne des futurs vignes de devrait
couler que dans une dizaine d'années
d'ici là surgiront sans doute encore de
nouveaux marchés
les austères mais très tendance aussi
les stages qui associe jeunes et marche
à pied un plan exceptionnel trouvé par
quelques naturopathe qui font payer près
de 100 euros par jour l'eau et le jus de
fruits distribués parcimonieusement leur
marcheurs l'objectif étant évidemment de
purger son organisme est d'assainir son
esprit jean françois cyr est et thierry
breton menu du jour 14 km de marche le
long de la plage de bénodet allure
modérée certes mais sans rien dans le
ventre
toujours prêt à manger sans pas dû
souvent très difficile cinq jours donc
elles n'ont rien mangé
ces jeunes femmes toutes parisienne
suivant bretagne un stage de jeunes
diététique l'effort et la privation de
nourriture et à éliminer les toxines ces
déchets que le corps accumule c'est une
purge de l'organisme on a plein de
carburant qu'un de réserve qui demande
qu'est ce que tu disais donc là on est
en train de voir dit qu'ils étaient
réserve
ça redonne fraîchement l'énergie et pour
le goûter
comme pour tous les autres repas au et
jus de fruits
les seuls vitamines de la journée rien
de médical dans tout ça
ce ne sont d'ailleurs pas des médecins
mais de jeunes naturopathe qui encadre
les participants nous ont fait en sorte
que les gens vivent mieux au quotidien
on n'a pas la prétention de les soigner
on n'a pas la prétention de les guérir
on n'est pas dans le domaine médical on
est dans le domaine du bien-être on
aspire attention et qui dit bien fière
d'y forcément yoga la maîtrise de son
corps aide à contrôler la faim dès qu'on
fait le yoga sa relance la vitalité dans
le corps ça freine d'élimination donc du
coup on sent beaucoup mieux
sixième et dernier jour dans la salle
d'un grand restaurant
enfin ces dames sont servis des algues
des brocolis avec une sauce légère
pas de viande la reprise de
l'alimentation se fait en douceur
il faut réadapter l'organisme bon une
bouée monde qui en a envie d'avoir un
peu de consistance texture en bouche
s'aggrave et bien payé seule la facture
est difficile à avaler 500 euros le
stage sans hébergement et donc s'en
remet pas ce coup les participants en
majorité des femmes affirment ne pas le
regretter
je n'ai à la maison leur serait
impossible distel quand on prépare le
repas pour les enfants
on peut pas se dire je bois une tisane
et après préparer des jeunes et des
enfants parce qu'évidemment en cuisinant
vous avez les odeurs vous avez
toutes ces choses que vous allez
préparer c'est évident qu'on peut pas
facilement pas faire un jeu entier soit
décision après une semaine sans manger
anne brigitte jackman a perdu que 2 kg
le jeune n'est pas un régime mais une
pause dans son alimentation à ne surtout
pas faire du jour au lendemain car mal
préparé un jeu ne peut être très
dangereux pour la santé
les monarques aime voyager mais cela ne
se déplace qu'en nombre puisqu'il s'agit
d'immenses papillons aux couleurs vives
immigrent du canada jusqu'au mexique
pour se reproduire
reportage au mexique justement martine
laroche-joubert et parce qu asus rio un
village voué au culte de la vierge
blotti dans la sierra la tradition au
mexique les auteurs de ces montagnes là
se cachent des sanctuaires unique au
monde
procès luis les explore depuis 11 ans il
prend un chemin escarpé au travers
d'immenses forêts de sapins à 3500
mètres d'altitude
soudain des centaines de millions de
papillons orange et les monarques dans
le royaume
il vient du canada à 3000 kilomètres
d'ici pour hiberner dans ces montagnes
fraîche et humide pendant cinq mois
ils vivent sur la réserve sa célèbre
domaine et l'abdomen et le plein des
gosses aient assez de réserve
l'epide là pour passer tout l'hiver une
longévité et une migration
extraordinaire il revient exactement à
la même forêt oui elle les arrière
grands parents et ils ont eu berné ils
ont jamais été là mais il revient au
même endroit exactement noël vous
l'expliquez comment s'il explicable un
mystère les aztèques croyez que les
monarques réincarner leurs guerriers
tués au combat
aujourd'hui les scientifiques se perdent
en hypothèse code génétique immuable
lecture du champ magnétique terrestre
nul ne sait pourquoi les papillons
reviennent toujours ici millar
sanctuaires sont en danger sont menacées
par les gens qui sont en train de couper
leurs habits tête de rabbit est ici des
coupeurs devoir abattre des arbres
clandestinement
comme ici et brouille les repères des
papillons france et luis et diego un
guide des forêts se battent pour leur
survie en replantant des arbres les
papillons représente une source de
travail importante pour notre communauté
nous essayons de lutter contre
l'abattage clandestin est de passer à
une économie du tourisme grâce au
tourisme
les villageois prennent conscience du
poids économique des papillons et
s'organisent pour les protéger les
monarques sont gardés comme des trésors
nous défendons les papillons quand ils
sont là nous surveillons la forêt pour
empêcher que les arbres soient
complétées assez les papillons même les
tout-petits connaissent le rythme des
saisons ils sont capables de retrouver
cet endroit ils en savent beaucoup plus
que nous sur la nature alors à quoi
servent les papillons à rien semble-t-il
et pourtant 100 papillon bat forêt sans
forêt pas d'eau et sao ce serait le
désert ici ces régions du mexique serait
complètement dépeuplée et nous partons
maintenant en terre inconnue pour un
rendez vous exceptionnel avec bruno solo
invité de l'émission qui découvrent la
mongolie ses chevaux et batbayar
l'éleveur alors bruno solo bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous avons notre
représentation au théâtre montparnasse
pour nous parler de cette expérience
c'était quand même inouï de se retrouver
en train de galoper dans les steppes de
mongolie
oui c'est inouï c'est un rêve de gosse
en plus j'imaginais pas un jour je
pourrai partir en mongolie ça fait
partie des pays que je rêvais de de
visiter mais voilà c'est les voyages
qu'on reporte sans cesse se compare pas
en mongolie quand on part n'importe où
c'est quand même un pays il n'y a pas
d'infrastructures hôtelières il n'y a
pas de routes etc
donc c'est des voyages qui se prépare
vie j'irai jamais je reporterais à
chaque fois et puis et puis là bien
entendu qu'on fabrique lopez m'a dit
c'est en mode lecture par j'étais ravie
de ce que je suis un je suis un amateur
de cheval et voilà et puis j'ai
découvert sur tout un pays et un homme
un homme batbayar à nos merveilleux
plein d'humour plein d'humour de
tendresse un homme rude et tous qui
ressemble à son pays
- 40 en hiver 40 en été c'est un pays où
on plaisante pas
vous rappelle à quel point vous êtes
petit point on vous voit dans ses
documentaires passé de l'inquiétude au
dollar mais au rire parce que petit à
petit justement ce personnage
exceptionnel 2 bat mayer se découvre il
est plutôt sévère au début un ben oui
parce que quand on est arrivé ils
considéraient après tout que j'étais
quelqu'un de susceptibles de l'aider
dans son exploitation dans sa ferme
c'est un éleveur avant tout et donc il
voulait tout de suite m'initier aux
travaux de la ferme qui sont évidemment
le très très loin de mon quotidien et
ils n'avaient pas vraiment le temps de
faire du sentimentalisme ici il pensait
à juste titre d'ailleurs je crois qu'ils
avaient raison que notre norolles nos
relations s'installerait au fur et à
mesure une fois que je serai bien
imprégné de son quotidien
et quand j'étais imprégné de ce
quotidien et c'est vrai qu'il y allait
avec certaine vigueur vous allez voir
dans le film
après là quelque chose s'est installée
entre nous qui la cuisine des plus
belles 6les la plus belle expérience de
ma vie en tout cas une rencontre aussi
court puisque je suis resté dix sept
jours à peu près là bas et créer de
telles relations amicales avec un homme
qui vit à des milliers de kilomètres de
chez nous savoir qu'aujourd'hui moment
je vous parle il est en train d'être
rentré son bétail ou de houe de tondre
ses moutons de faire quelque chose
savoir qu'il ya un ami qui habite là-bas
en mongolie parce que c'est vraiment un
ami c'est déchirant les moments le
moment où je le quitte mais il ya
tellement moment aussi qu'ils sont
drôles qui sont parce que il a alors je
vois pas faire objet a été peut-être que
tous les membres de mongols ne le sont
pas et lui il a un humour absolument
féroce et de ce point de vue là on s'est
plutôt bien retrouver parce qu'il aime
bien charrier et je suis pas le dernier
de ma classe non merci bruno en tout cas
d'être venu témoigner on vous retrouve
après ce journal pour ce rendez vous en
terre inconnue donc en mongolie avec
frédéric lopez avant de refermer cette
édition je vous en rappelle le principal
titre la mort de benazir buttho tuées
dans un attentat-suicide cet après midi
et l'issue d'un meeting dans la banlieue
d'islamabad l'ex premier ministre et
leader de l'opposition pakistanaise
était rentré dans son pays à peine deux
mois dans tout le pays la non
de sa mort a suscité des scènes de
violences l'armée a été placée en alerte
rouge et trois jours de deuil national
ont été décrétés
c'est la fin du journal merci à vous
d'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
présentée par laurent romejko suivi du
point route de julia un pascal 20h50
donc rendez vous en terre inconnue avec
bruno solo demain à 20 heures et pendant
tout le week-end vous retrouvez au 10è
galerie très bonne soirée sur france 2
je vous retrouve lundi à 13h au revoir
l'info en continu cette année sur france
2 point fr
où